[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Awesome, then let's jump in
here. Well, welcome to the Data
Science Hangout, everybody. Nice to
see you all back here.
And if this is your
first time joining us,
a special welcome to you as
well. It's so nice to meet you.
I'm Rachael, I lead
customer marketing at Posit.
I like to start asking this,
but is this anybody's
first Data Science Hangout?
Say hi in the chat because we'd
love to welcome you in, and
say hello to anybody joining
for the first time too.
But this is our open space
to chat about data science
leadership, questions
you're facing,
and getting to hear about
what's going on in the world of
data across
different industries.
So we're here every Thursday
at the same time, same place.
If you're watching this
recording on YouTube later,
the link to add it to your
calendar will be in the details
below as well.
I said every Thursday,
but just a heads up we will
be off next week for the
Thanksgiving holiday.
But at the Hangouts,
we're all dedicated to
making this a welcoming environment
for everyone. Love hearing
from everybody no matter your
years of experience, your
titles, the languages you work
in, or industry.
It is totally OK to
just listen in here.
Maybe you're walking your dog,
you're on your lunch break,
or just want to listen
in for the first one.
But there's also ways you can
jump in and ask questions,
or provide your
own perspective.
So you can jump in by
raising your hand on Zoom. And I'll
keep my eye out. You can
put questions in the Zoom chat,
and feel free to put a little star next
to it if you want me to read it.
Or I can call on you
to introduce yourself and add some context.
And then we also
have a Slido link,
which Curtis will share in a
second here where you can ask
questions anonymously too.
Just before we get
started, I wanted to share
if you are hiring, feel
free to share any roles in
the chat here that's
definitely not spammy to us.
The Biogen team
actually shared one
with me earlier today,
so I just wanted to share
it in the chat there.
One more shout out. If
anybody is in Boston,
Kevin and I are hosting Tidy
Tuesday meetup tonight. Yes, on a Thursday.
But that's at
Microsoft in Cambridge.
So I'm just going to put
that in there as well.
But with that,
I am so excited to introduce
my co-host for today,
Stephanie Lussier, manager
of biostatistics at Moderna.
And Stephanie, I'd love to
have you introduce yourself,
and share a little bit
about your role and also something
you like to do outside of work.
STEPHANIE LUSSIER: Sure.
So thank you for the
brief introduction. As you said,
I'm currently a manager
of biostatistics at Moderna,
and I sit in our specialty
data analytics team.
So a little bit
about my background.
I graduated with a
master's in biostats
in 2017, and then
proceeded to work at a CRO,
a contract research
organization for five years.
And then during that time,
I had what some might call
a little bit more of a
traditional statistician role
within the clinical
trial realm,
and was doing open
source projects,
kind of more on the side
like a 20% time kind of deal.
And so in 2022,
I kind of got to the point
where I really wanted that to
be a bigger part of my
role. And so that's where I found
my current position at Moderna.
And so I'm in the specialty
data analytics team.
And our mission kind of in
simple terms is to just use
clinical data with modern
open source technologies
to really enable
internal decision-making.
So that's where I am now,
and happy to talk more about it.
And
outside of work,
I kind of collect hobbies
like Pokemon cards.
And as a result of that,
I'm definitely like jack of
all trades, master of none,
which I'm OK with. And so
some of those hobbies include yoga,
that's kind of a
big one for me.
I've been learning
to play tennis.
I make a lot of sourdough.
I'm learning to throw pots on the
wheel. And
I do like to travel, and when I
travel I do like to scuba dive. So
I'm happy to talk about
hobbies for an entire hour.
I love them. I hope
everyone has awesome hobbies. Yeah.
RACHEL DEMPSEY: Wait,
can you tell me a bit more
about what throwing pots on the wheel means.
- So like using clay
to make pottery.
And so a lot of that
at my skill level means making
cups and bowls that aren't very
symmetrical but
are supposed to be.
It's very relaxing.
For me like I can't draw
at all, or paint, or anything of
that type, and so this is
kind of an art form that
I can do a little bit. [LAUGHS]
- I love it. That's awesome.
STEPHANIE LUSSIER: Oh, I wanted
to throw in one little tidbit,
if you don't mind.
So with all due respect to past
data leaders,
I thought a little bit about
what my goal is being on the
Data Science Hangout today. And
for those that don't know, the
leaders are great but the chat
is where it's at.
And so my goal is just for
people to have fun in the chat. So
go crazy. It has
resources, it has debates,
it has fun topics.
And if you've never
participated in the chat
before, I'd encourage you
to do so if you want to.
RACHEL DEMPSEY: I love it.
Thank you so much for that
call out to the chat. Yes,
the chat is always
a party. [LAUGHS]
I see the excitement starting
already in there. [LAUGHS]
Well, Stephanie,
while we are waiting for some
questions to come in from everybody here,
I know something that we talked
a bit about is becoming a
manager for the first time.
And I'm curious if
there's something that
you've learned or you had
to learn throughout this process
of becoming a manager that
you'd be able to share with us.
- Sure.
So a lot of pieces of this.
In my previous role, like I
said more as a traditional statistician,
you work within
clinical teams. And so
you end up doing some
management of statistical
outputs. So that
is kind of managing
statisticians and programmers
on a project level.
And I think that was
really good preparation for being an
actual true manager.
And so now I'm on a team.
We have seven full time
employees, and seven
contractors, and
starting to pick up part of
the true management pieces of that.
But let's see, as far
as what I've learned,
there's a lot of paperwork
parts of it. And so hopefully
anyone becoming a manager has
some sort of mentor walking
them through that part of it.
For example, requesting a
laptop is a pretty difficult
goal to achieve apparently.
Shout out to our awesome
digital team who helps with that.
So learning like those little
technical pieces of it is a
whole new world to just take
on slowly and ask questions.
I think that's the
most important thing.
And then as far as
actual management, I think just
forming a relationship
with people,
working closely together,
asking them to ask questions,
just really creating a
comfortable space has been
really important for me.
RACHEL DEMPSEY: Thank you. STEPHANIE
LUSSIER: Yeah.
- I see Bill jumped in
right away with a question,
and I know you said
you want me to ask it.
But the question was, when you graduate--
or what is the language that
you use in your academic
program? Did you need to learn
SAS when you joined the CRO?
is the question. And-- STEPHANIE
LUSSIER: Sure.
- --maybe the acronyms you will
expand on them a bit too. [CHUCKLES]
- Yeah. I'm doing my very
best with not over using acronyms.
So please catch me if I do.
Yeah, so in the clinical
trial world, the main
statistical language that
is used right now is SAS.
I don't know what SAS
stands for. It's fine.
But it's a
statistical programming language.
So during my grad school, I
was lucky enough to learn both
SAS and R, and
even some Python.
And I think that really
guided where I ended up today.
So SAS was taught in certain
classes that I had, and in
other classes as the
professors favored R.
And I think the reason I really
ended up on the R path was that
my main thesis project was done
in R. And so that really gave
me a strong foundation so that
when I started my first role,
I was definitely
expected to use
SAS and that more
traditional setting.
But I was able to connect
with the people in my first organization
who did use R. And that really
kicked off thinking more
about developing with R,
and what R in the clinical
trial space looks like.
RACHEL DEMPSEY: Thank you. STEPHANIE
LUSSIER: Yeah.
-
Something that you and I
had chatted a little bit about
before is that you've kind
of realized like people don't want
to look at these standard
tables listings and figures.
Which I just learned that's
what TLFS means when I see that
listed are named in pharma.
But I'm curious,
in building tools for
internal decision-making,
what has been really helpful
for you in communicating? STEPHANIE
LUSSIER: Yeah.
So the fun thing too about
the TLF abbreviation is that it
goes by many abbreviations.
So watch out for that.
It can be TLF, TFL, TLG, TGL,
and that all means
the same thing.
- It was right on top of it
in the chat too. [LAUGHS]
- And why is it like that?
I think that's just
to confuse people.
And I think that's a
common theme with abbreviations in
clinical trials. So to
actually answer the question, yeah,
a big part of my role is
creating visualizations for
internal decision-making.
And so we think a lot about
what is the best way to do that.
I think one of
the most important questions is,
what is the question that
someone is trying to answer?
And who is the end user?
And so for example,
a lot of times the end user
for us is say the executive committee.
And so people on the
executive committee
at Moderna at least are
highly skilled professionals.
They're not looking for a
green button or a red button.
They want to know
what were the results?
And they want to see it in a
visually pleasing
straightforward display. But they
also still want to know
some key statistical elements.
And so that's actually part of
the reason why a lot of the
people on our team
have a statistics background is
because we are still displaying
confidence intervals and
risk ratios in our displays.
And so that's an example
where we know the audience,
and we know the questions
they're going to ask.
Another example would be
we create say visualizations that
are going to be used by
the clinical team that want to
look at data in an ongoing way.
And so you might think about
how well those people know this
data, and they want to
know every nitty-gritty about it.
And so that's where
something like interactive applications
really comes into play.
So that as they form
their own questions
they can answer
those questions.
RACHEL DEMPSEY: That's great.
Can you share maybe an example for
us or an example use case where
people were able to answer some of
their own questions with an interactive app?
STEPHANIE LUSSIER:
Sure. So I'm working--
one of the big projects that
I work on both internally and
externally right now is on
patient profiles. And so the
whole goal with
patient profiles
is that you can look
at one particular participant in a
study. And the primary uses
there is really for safety.
So you could look
at, say their labs,
basic demographics information,
what we call adverse events.
So any safety signals
that happen through the study.
And so we had a participant
that had an unexpected
response in a biomarker.
And so they were able to
use the patient profile to look at
when that particular
biomarker uptick occurred,
what else was going on for
that particular participant.
RACHEL DEMPSEY: Thank you.
I think Bill's question maybe
expands a bit on
this. Let's see. STEPHANIE
LUSSIER: Sure.
RACHEL DEMPSEY: Was that
that visualization was
that a Shiny application.
I think Bill's question was,
have you developed Shiny-based
apps for your internal users?
And have you ended up using
the same interactive or static
visualizations in drill-downs when
interacting with the FDA?
STEPHANIE LUSSIER: OK,
that's like three questions. RACHEL
DEMPSEY: Yeah, we can break we can
break it up a bit, yeah. STEPHANIE
LUSSIER: No,
that's OK.
So
much to say here. So the
particular example I provided
is actually all being
powered by non-Shiny interactivity.
And there's been a couple of
great talks about this topic lately.
[INAUDIBLE]
gave a hilarious
talk at Posit Conf
about this. And my
mentor, Agustin Calatroni,
also had a recorded talk at
our pharma where he kind of touched
on this as well.
And so kind of with a judicious
use of cross talk plotly
interactive tables.
You can make an
interactive HTML document
that has a limited but
pretty good capabilities.
And so that is the current
platform for that particular patient profile.
So yeah, if you're not
familiar with that setup,
I do think it's powerful.
In my previous company, we
didn't really have a good
hosting platform,
and so we were able to
really utilize that setup
to create interactive reports.
Like at a high level
the limitation is that the
interactivity happens on one
level sort of, and there's
no recalculation
happening of the data.
You're essentially filtering the data.
But you can really do
a lot with that setup.
So then
moving to like Shiny land,
it's definitely something
that our team uses.
We have a variety of
different visualizations.
And so that decision is kind
part of what we talked about
earlier when you get say
a data visualization request deciding
what is the right technology.
And so if more and more
exploration is the goal, then Shiny
I think is the way to go.
And we definitely utilize that.
And then I think the third
question is about sending that
to the FDA. And
that's not something that
we're doing right now.
But I think probably a
lot of folks are following
the R submissions group, and they've
done a pilot to look at
what a Shiny app to the
FDA could look like.
And they're going
to be doing more
utilizing the web R framework,
which is a hot, hot
exciting topic right now
that could apply really well for
this concept of Shiny to FDA.
So many answers.
RACHEL DEMPSEY: Right, great job.
[LAUGHTER]
And I guess probably fun to
just throw it out here as well
that some of the team from
the FDA is actually going to be
joining us at the Hangout
on February 1, so putting it
out there so people know as
well. But I see a lot of
love for cross talk in the chat.
It feels like we should have
some sort of event on that at
some point. [LAUGHS] STEPHANIE
LUSSIER: Let's talk
event. Very awesome.
RACHEL DEMPSEY: Awesome. Sita,
I see you asked a
question in the chat.
Do you want to jump in here?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, hi, thanks.
So I'm curious
from a more management
perspective, how did you
navigate this
transition from a more
day-to-day interactions with
more biostatisticians who knew
the same language and were
talking the same way versus to
working at Moderna where
you kind of have to interface
with a whole different group of people?
Say biologists,
data scientists,
very diverse kind
of group of people
assuming that it was less
diverse in the sense of having
more biostatisticians
in your previous role.
And kind of what
challenges did you have?
And how did you deal with that?
- OK, yeah, I love
that question.
I think it's an awesome
part about the clinical trial world,
is that you do get to interface
with people in so many different roles.
And I would say that at
my previous position I did
interface with a lot
of different types of people
already. And so maybe
that was good preparation.
Working with clinicians on the trial
I even used to have phone
calls with people at the sites.
That was always fun to feel
more a part of the trial.
So I think I definitely
already had cross-functional area training.
So then moving to Moderna,
I think part of the
difference is the group that we're
in now is very much like
a support team.
So we have presents
on every study.
And our role is a little
bit like we're here to help you,
how do we help?
Does this help you?
And so gaining a pretty
good understanding of, what would
help people is really important so
that we can deliver tools that
are useful.
Did that answer your
question a little bit?
AUDIENCE: Yes,
thank you so much.
STEPHANIE LUSSIER:
Thank you, yeah.
- Ross, I think you had
a question in the chat,
do you want to
jump in here next?
AUDIENCE: Sure, thanks.
I similar to you wound up
sending reports up and stuff,
and sometimes the feedback that I'll get
is good and sometimes it's like, eh.
What's one thing that the
leadership does that's good,
that's helpful to you, that
gets them the report
that they actually want?
- Yeah, I love that.
So like what is good feedback
and what is less helpful feedback?
I'm thinking,
good feedback
is for them to tell us how and why
a report was or wasn't useful.
So that we can then apply
it to future reports.
And so the why I think is
important. And maybe you have
to ask the why
because if they just say
this didn't help,
that's not useful.
So getting like a better
understanding of what they were
looking for, maybe
an understanding of our report
answers the question that they
asked, hopefully.
But if that question changed
over time and that's why the
report is no longer helpful,
a little bit of insight
into how that question might have
changed or why that question
might have changed helps us predict
in the future
how questions might change or
how we can provide supplemental
materials that might
answer those changing questions.
So yeah, I think the takeaway on
that is it's OK to turn it
into a conversation and probe a
little bit more so that you can
move forward and
improve for the future.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
STEPHANIE LUSSIER: Yeah.
Did you have any thoughts
you wanted to add, Ross?
AUDIENCE: I'll just
make it really quick. STEPHANIE
LUSSIER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I have a
lot of prior careers,
one of which I'm actually
a professional counselor
with a master's in
the whole thing.
So to me listening is really,
really, really critical.
I think it's almost more
important than the analysis.
So just make sure that I
really truly understand what the question is.
And if I can give a
professional counselor tip for
just a second, also
find out what it is not
because when you
find out what it is,
you might go four miles
down that path and find, oh,
it's actually something
slightly different.
I was working on that.
No, we don't want that.
Is it this and not that?
And once you do that,
a lot of things clear up,
and then it's easy to move forward.
- Awesome. Yeah, I previously
did a lot of work on
manuscript writing.
And so in traditional clinical
trials, you have your endpoints
that are pre-written, and you
answer those endpoints that are
pre-specified. And sometimes
in a more exploratory
biomarker manuscript setting,
there can be a lot
of back and forth.
Like you're talking about
with questions changing over time.
And so keeping the
conversation flowing was always
important to really
narrow the scope,
and try to find the
answers that they were looking for.
RACHEL DEMPSEY:
I see a lot of great thoughts
on this topic too in the chat.
I don't know if, Catherine,
you wanted to share
your thoughts here too.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I was just--
I'll kind of repeat what I
said in the chat is one of the
things that I learned
to ask for is like,
what questions are my
leadership being asked that led
them to ask me to do something?
Because how they're
interpreting their own--
the questions that
they're being asked.
And then there's three
levels of information distillation
before they ask you
for a piece of math,
or a piece of reporting,
or a visualization.
And so then you make the thing
that you think they were asking for,
but it doesn't really meet
the ask that their leadership asked
them for. And so there's a
little bit of a cycle there.
And so getting plugged into
meetings where you can listen
to how your leadership talks
about these kinds of things,
or being forwarded emails or
things like that can really
help you get a broader
picture of where your organization fits
within the broader thing. So
OK, this is how the reports
that I deliver are used by
these other teams to get more
of a sense of like, OK,
what information is actually
important to the ultimate
decision-making?
- Yeah, one of the comments
that you touched on, Catherine,
is something that we kind
of prioritize in our team.
And that's asking to
get invited to the meetings
to
parse down the amount
of distillation that occurs.
And so no one wants a
calendar full of meetings when there's
lots of deep work to do.
But when their important
asking to get invited,
so you can hear the
whole conversation instead of the summary.
RACHEL DEMPSEY: Lisa,
I see you had some nice
feedback on this as
well. Do you want to--
do you want to share that?
- I'm sorry, feel like
I wrote a lot today.
So are you talking about
just the comparison to
feedback from students or-- RACHEL
DEMPSEY: Yeah. Yeah,
the [AUDIO OUT]
sense of teaching, yeah.
- Yeah. No, I was just more--
I don't think I have much
to add besides that it just sort
of triggered in my mind that
it reminded me of teaching.
And when I get these responses,
especially when I first started
teaching that they would be like,
you're awful, or you're
really nice. And I was like,
oh, I feel really lovely
that you think I'm nice,
or I feel terrible that
you think I'm awful. But
neither of those
really help me.
So I always ask them to
be specific as possible.
But I've never
thought of asking
someone at work
for that specific
feedback. So that was
a nice connection is all
I was saying. [CHUCKLES] RACHEL
DEMPSEY: Thank you
for sharing. Yeah,
I'm trying to call out some
of the chat comments as well
because I know when people
watch the recording,
they don't get the advantage
of getting to see all these
amazing comments too.
I know--
let's see, Adrian,
you asked a question in
the chat a bit earlier.
Do you to jump in?
- Yeah, let me see if I can
recall it and restate
it pretty clearly.
I'm interested in, Stephanie,
at Moderna and with the
profile of work you're doing.
How recyclable is
sort of those analysis
or those reports?
And if you want
a bit of context,
I spent a lot of time
trying to not do anything multiple times.
So I'm curious if
the biostats area or at least
with your team if there is a
lot of opportunity to library your
sort of starting points
or what have you.
- Yes, great question.
The short, very short answer
is yes. There's a lot of
recyclability. And
I think a lot of similar
teams as well as mine are working
on creating internal
packages that help with that
recyclability.
But something like it's kind
of been on my mind lately is
making sure that when
you're creating functions, modules, whatever,
you're still allowing for
customization. Because
at least in my experience
what people in clinical
teams they want to add stuff.
They want to say, can
we look at this too?
Can you add this facet?
Even
little details, and so as
we go on making progress
in creating an internal package system.
That's something that we're trying
to keep in mind is
finding that sweet spot
between out of the box, boom,
here you go. I made you
this plot, and allowing for
customization.
Thumbs up. Awesome. [LAUGHS]
- I want to jump to a few
of the anonymous questions too. And one was,
do you have any advice for
a recent graduate trying to get
her foot in the door? It's
a bit hard to do currently.
- OK.
We're all with you.
It's not easy.
My
job search to switch jobs took
what felt like a long time.
I don't want to
put a number on it.
Like I was always told
statisticians can get a new job
so quickly, and I was really
picky in my situation.
And so it wasn't
quick. And I did have
fear surrounding that
I look back on now,
and it all makes sense.
But for thinking about
someone with less experience,
I saw the chat going this
direction last week which is a
topic that I think is
really cool to talk about is
the presence of
an online GitHub
repository because I think
there's arguments for and
against this. But I think in
a position of being a recent
grad, that's something that
I would think about doing is
do some little tiny projects and
put them on GitHub just to
demonstrate your
programming skills.
And then in the clinical
trial space, if you're having
difficulty, I would suggest
looking at contract research
organizations. I learned
so much in that role.
And I think they have
a lot of positions
hopefully for more entry level.
Like I hope I'm not making
too big of generalizations, I think
sometimes the pharma side
of thing does look for more
experience. And there are more
entry level associate type
roles in the CRO world. So
that's something to look into
and read more about.
And then another thing
I would think about is
I don't know exactly
your background, but the
clinical trials world has a
lot of clinical trials knowledge.
And so trying to find
some resources online to become
familiar with what a
clinical trial looks like.
We have data
standards called CDISC
to do a little bit of
research about that.
I think that would make you
really stand out as a candidate.
RACHEL DEMPSEY: Thank you.
Matt,
I see you had a
question a bit earlier.
Do you want to jump
in and read that one?
AUDIENCE: Sure.
So I was curious.
You talked about some of
the dashboards you've built.
And I'm just curious what's
the limiting principle for how much
interactivity to give people?
Because I've kind of found that
there are two sides to that
continuum. One, you can
just keep building the app,
and building the app,
and adding more functionality.
But you want to deliver it.
And then the more
content you add--
the more functionality you add
to it the more possibility--
someone else pointed out that
there's a possibility that
people are going to
derive insights that
aren't necessarily
true or meaningful.
But then on the flip side,
you know that the one thing
you don't implement is the thing
you're going to get asked for. So
where do you draw the line on
what to do and
what to leave out?
STEPHANIE LUSSIER:
That's a big question.
It's difficult to nail down.
I think
in my particular realm
of things, you can--
I definitely think about it
along the lines of where a
study is progressing. So
in the early, early phases
of a clinical trial,
things or even preclinical things
can be much more exploratory.
And so when exploratory is the
goal, hypothesis generating is the goal,
go crazy
and put a disclaimer. [LAUGHS]
That there are things discoverable
here that need to be
proven outside of
this application.
And then when you
work your way down to
questions that are
more formulated,
a researcher has
really provided
the question they're
trying to answer.
I would--
that's where I would think
about limiting it and trying to
really just answer the
question that's being asked,
and limit the back and forth because
there's a whole
theory behind this.
But when you're in phase
3 of a clinical trial,
the question
should be laid out,
and the question
should be answerable.
And that upholds the entire
integrity of the trial.
So that's kind of
how I think about it.
AUDIENCE: No, that's
great. Thank you.
I also really appreciate
the disclaimer.
STEPHANIE LUSSIER: Yeah,
use disclaimers. [LAUGHS]
AUDIENCE: Right.
RACHEL DEMPSEY:
I see Abigail and Jesse you
had some thoughts on this topic
too. Do you want
to jump in here?
I'm not sure if you're in
places where you can jump in or
not, but I'll give
a second here.
AUDIENCE: Oh, was this
about interactivity? RACHEL
DEMPSEY: Yeah.
- Oh, yeah, no I was
just saying, I don't know, real dashboards--
dashboards are tough
because people do--
like you give people self-serve
analytics and then they come to
conclusions which
are wrong. Sometimes,
so figuring out how to
manage that I think can--
I found that to be difficult.
So sometimes I just
want to give somebody,
like I wrote you a paper,
I made you a PowerPoint thing
as useful as the interactivity
definitely can be--
RACHEL DEMPSEY: Definitely.
Kevin, I see you had a
question in the chat.
Want to jump in here?
AUDIENCE: Sure. Yeah. [LAUGHS]
What was my question?
- Sorry.
I know when there's a lot
of chat it gets hard to remember
what our questions were.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it was about--
oh, that's right, I remember.
It was about deep work.
And as a manager,
and the question was basically,
are you able to manage to carve
out time to do deep work still
or do you have to
delegate most of that?
Or how do you kind
of handle that?
STEPHANIE LUSSIER: Yeah.
So
generally, I would say
that my manager workload--
like workload as a manager is not 40
hours a week in any way right now.
And so I definitely find time to
carve out for deep work. And I also
am not overloaded on meetings,
which I know what that
looks like from previous
experience as well.
And so it definitely is doable.
I think part of that is
because our group is so young.
Everyone is heads down
creating stuff, doing work, focusing,
and so
that kind of contributes to
an overall environment where we're all
getting in hours
for deep work. Yeah.
- But do you end
up having to hit--
attend lots of meetings that they don't
have to go to to interface with
the people that you guys
are serving or other management and
things like that?
- Yeah, right now I really
feel like that is being handled
well. Like the meetings
that I'm attending are
relevant and helpful.
And I could see, of course,
how that could change.
But
yeah, I think it's
something to always
keep in the front of your
mind is time resourcing.
I'm a fan of time blocking
in my calendar. And so
always asking the question,
do I need to be
at this meeting?
What am I getting
out of this meeting?
And you don't always hit
the nail on the head.
You go to a meeting that
you shouldn't have been at or
you miss a meeting that you
should have been at.
But just always keeping it
in the forefront of your mind
I think is an important skill.
AUDIENCE: All right,
thanks so much. STEPHANIE
LUSSIER: Yeah. RACHEL
DEMPSEY:
There's something I've been thinking
a lot about recently as well.
Like initially when you get
invited to a meeting with a new
team it feels good.
Like, oh, I'm--
they want my point of
view in this conversation.
And then when I realize, OK,
that meeting is every
week or every other week.
At what point can
you then say, OK,
no I don't think I need to
be at this meeting every week. And
how do you
communicate that to people that know
you're just not going to attend? STEPHANIE
LUSSIER: Yeah.
I think as
soon as you're saying
to yourself, is this useful?
It might not be useful.
And so just making it a
conversation I think. But it's not easy.
But yeah, I think
it's something for any
career person to always
be thinking about.
- I see a few ideas here in
the chat. Donald, do you want to jump in?
AUDIENCE: Sure.
Just as far as carving out deep
work time I think I had some
questions too, so I'll
try and answer those.
I usually block out two to
three hour chunks multiple times a week.
I think it's also recommended in
boards book to do that too,
and I've been doing it ever
since and it's been extremely helpful.
I think Jared you asked if
people ever complain that I'm
never available. Some times, but
I also notify my director
who I report to like,
oh, I'm doing this,
this is really important
because I'm a knowledge worker
I need this time to do that,
and he's completely on
board with it. So usually,
we kind of loop in if we need
discussion of priorities to see
if anything else needs to happen.
- I see that Frank
is on the call,
and I don't mean
to call on you,
but it's something that's always stuck
with me that you said, Frank,
is like you color code some of
the meetings that you have on your calendar,
and the ones that give you
energy are a certain color and
the ones that are--
[LAUGHS]
and maybe I'm putting
words in your mouth,
but are more draining
a different color.
And I thought that was a really
interesting approach too.
STEPHANIE LUSSIER: I hope,
Frank, your calendar doesn't face
all of your coworkers
in that case.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: But honestly,
even if it does,
that's fine with me.
And
so most of this came
when I was at Target,
and Target huge company,
most of us work in
huge companies. And
yeah, I mean,
in those cases I was always
pretty honest about that stuff.
I was like, hey, yeah,
I'm going to show up.
Like this is a little
bit draining for me,
but I know it's important
for me to hear this.
I know it's important
for me to be here.
When you do the color
coding, it makes it very easy to
see like, hey, red, red, red, red, red,
and then the last red
meeting is something that's really important.
And you have to be paying
attention and on top of it.
And I mean, all of us love
to find patterns in data even if
your sample size
is really small.
And then being able to
just reflect on that, and notice
that, oh, man,
there's no way I'm going to be
able to give my focus, and attention,
and 100% at like this really
important meeting to the one on
one with a team member or
the big meeting with the VP.
If you can know
how you will be,
and then sharing that with
other people around you like
people are surprisingly or
maybe not surprisingly willing
to adjust. So I've always
been a fan of that visibility.
If it rubs people
the wrong way,
it's going to be even worse
for the whole organization if you
show up to this really
important meeting and you're
drained. So it's
been my philosophy.
- OK, I'm thinking of a scatter
plot where we're plotting
importance versus
passion, maybe. And
so really important,
no passion kind of
still got to go.
Less important tons of passion
when there's time for it.
Like we have quadrants.
Is that along the lines
of your thought process?
- Yeah, but the way
you describe that and the
way I'm visualizing it, like
none of this stuff
lives in a silo.
Like it's all connected and
especially the series of
meetings leading up to
something important before you
can go on a walk if
you're in Minneapolis and in a Skyway,
and like re
re-energize yourself.
So I'm not exactly sure,
maybe we can put together a
three dimensional scatter plot,
so we can see these things.
Like time would be your other axis. STEPHANIE
LUSSIER: Time of
day is important,
and that's your
third dimension? OK.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
- Very cool.
- [LAUGHS]
We should write that one up.
- Yeah.
RACHEL DEMPSEY: Mike, I
see you had a question
earlier on
as a consultant when somebody asks,
can you help me do x?
Do you want to jump in and
continue that question?
-
I think that was very
much related to what you were
talking about
previously on the-- RACHEL
DEMPSEY: OK.
AUDIENCE: --why is someone
asking for a report?
But it
would be interesting to
hear what Stephanie thinks.
That sometimes I get these
messages that go, Mike, can you
get this package for me?
Or could you show me
how to do that thing?
Whether any context. And
as a consultant, you
might think, well,
I'll just jump
in and I'll help.
I'll just do it help
them get that thing.
But then if you unpick it
you realize that actually there's a
whole world of either there's
a better solution or there's a
simpler thing that they
could do or it's related to
back to the why question.
So
you can be the
helpful consultant,
or you can actually
do something that makes--
that eliminates
tech debt or makes
it's easier to
maintain or something.
STEPHANIE LUSSIER: Yeah,
I think I'm coming to mind
with examples just within my own team
of getting a ping saying,
how do I--
Stephanie, how do I make
this access log 10? And
it's probably a good idea to
first ask why are you making
that access log 10?
These kinds of things,
to try to make sure
you're solving the right
question. Yeah, I like that.
- Brennan, I see you
just asked a question.
Want to jump in here next?
- Yes, ma'am. The question
I wanted to ask you,
what's the most fulfilling
project you have worked on so
far in your career?
STEPHANIE LUSSIER: Oh, I
really like that question.
It
gives me a good moment
to reflect back.
We talk about data science
and clinical trials, but
clinical trials are a big deal.
They affect people's lives. And
that definitely is a huge motivator
for me in my day to day.
And it's always important to think
back like this data is a
person giving up their time,
giving up their selves to help
improve science. And
I'm giving myself chills.
Like it's just such an
awesome thing to be a part of.
And so
there's so much cool
stuff happening at Moderna
that could make very
big advancements in the science
world. But me personally,
my answer definitely has to
be that in my previous role,
I worked on a really
big food allergy trial.
And it would essentially be
the first actual treatment,
like a antibody approved
to treat food allergy.
And it was a
behemoth of a study.
No one wanted to work on
it. It was very complicated,
but it was so rewarding
to think that you're helping children
who can't have lunch
in the cafeteria
change their lives. And so
I was really proud of the
work I did on that study.
It was an awesome team. And
they've completed
it without me, so
yeah, it was a really
good experience.
Oh, and I'll add to that.
I had a colleague--
once I was off the study I
had a former colleague whose
child joined the study. So
that's super cool to actually
feel so connected to the study.
And so again, hearing from
his point of view, oh my gosh,
we're at the doctors all the time,
this is so much work. And on
our side, that's like this
schedule of events is insane.
I don't know how to program
the visits data set.
Those two things go hand in
hand, and our side is easier.
Like I think always
keep that in mind.
Yeah, thanks for asking that.
RACHEL DEMPSEY: All right.
Thank you. I love that
question, Brennan.
Natalia, I see
you had a question
earlier in the Hangout.
You want to jump in here?
- Yeah, sure. We are on such
a great note, don't know if
switching back to
programming. [LAUGHS]
Yeah, but thank you. So
you mentioned that Moderna
is kind of open to open
source and those tools. So I'm very
curious if in your day to
day work you're using any
Pharmaverse packages, or any
other pharma-related open source packages.
And overall,
how are you approaching the
open source projects at Moderna?
Are you going to release some
open source yours as well
within your company?
So stuff like this.
- Yeah. Great. We love--
like I mean, I love
open source, I think that's why
we're here, and let's hang out
because we all love open source.
So yeah, your question had a
lot of different parts again. So
as far as our team
using Pharmaverse, so a little
background for non-pharma
people, Pharmaverse is a
collection of packages
contributed to by all
different pharma companies
as well as CROs.
And the aim of the Pharmaverse
packages is largely to do with
submissions. So actually,
putting a drug in front
of the FDA for approval.
And that is not where my
group is using open source
software at this time.
We're very much keeping our eyes
and ears open to it. And
if that's something
you're interested in.
And you haven't yet
watched Novo Nordisk's YouTube video,
someone can put it in the chat,
that's very groundbreaking,
very exciting.
It was presented beautifully.
And we're very happy at
Moderna to see these companies laying
the path for us.
I'm very appreciative of those
companies as well as all the
initiatives that surround that.
So yeah, that's not totally
our focus. And so I don't see
us using Pharmaverse
packages a ton.
That being said, we have
a safety stats group that are
also open source folks
and they have developed similar
table packages
for
what looks more like an
FDA reporting output.
And again, those are currently
being used internally.
But as a part of that work,
and this is to answer another
part of your question,
there is a member of that
team or several members of that team
that do participate
in Pharmaverse open source
like the Falcon package.
And so
in general, I find that
leadership is very open to
open source collaboration.
RACHEL DEMPSEY: Thank you.
Let's see.
If-- I
know as we get to the end
of the time here.
If you have a question that
we maybe missed in the chat among
all the amazing
conversation in there,
please raise your hand here
so we can get to it as well.
But Jared,
I see you had a question a
little bit earlier if you want
to jump in next.
AUDIENCE: Sure. Can
you guys hear me OK?
I guess
in the CRO space you bring up
a few good points. But I think
for me it's more like
transitioning and toeing the
line between a statistician
or a programming role.
I've seen a lot more
individual struggle going from
a programmer to a statistician,
then from a statistician
to a programmer.
And so the thing that I
keep finding myself wondering is like,
do you find yourself
missing some programming aspects where
you're kind of just inundated
with writing up SOPs and
protocols versus actually getting to do
some of the work? And then
from that same
coin
going back and thinking
the role that you're in as
a statistician if it's more of a
standard role, or
one of discovery,
and trying to stay in that
niche or being more kind of
fluid in
the roles that you
take on. Like you said,
you're very picky
about that for that--
I don't know if that had
partially had to do with the reason.
- Yeah.
Really great question.
It's interesting to see I've
seen colleagues over time
switching between
programming and statistics,
and that's always kind of
telling about a person's passion
and how that might change over
time I think it's really cool.
I actually think right now in
my current role I have a very
good mix of
statistics, programming management
kind of all blended together
which for me works well. I
like doing all of those things.
And like to your--
a couple of things. So I
think we're going to see maybe the
definition between
statisticians and programmers
change over time
where that line is drawn,
and that future roles might
start looking a little bit different.
I think there's already several
companies that are kind of
calling everyone a data scientist
now and blurring those lines.
And so I think within
that idea of blurred lines
it's important to
know what you like,
and advocate for yourself
to do what you like.
And then another piece of
that, that's something I
really like to speak about
this when I'm interviewing candidates
for our team
is to have an open
conversation about--
like you said, I
was seeking out
this change from a traditional
statistician to what looks a
little bit more like a
data scientist, you might say.
But like fresh grads to
have a conversation about what that
means and what that means
in terms of your career,
I always like to
have that conversation because the
industry as it stands right now
has more of those
traditional roles.
And maybe it will
change over time,
but just kind of having
an open conversation about it because
it might be a new
concept for people that
are new to the industry.
RACHEL DEMPSEY: Thank you. STEPHANIE
LUSSIER: Yeah.
- So
maybe at some point I'll pull
all of the answers to this
question together,
but I know we've asked it
in a few different Hangouts.
Is there a piece of career
advice that you've been given
or that you've given others
that stands out to you?
STEPHANIE LUSSIER: Sure.
So
when I joined
the CRO, we've
talked so much, about
back in 2017, I was just
very lucky to be scooped up
by a very passionate mentor
who has 100% guided my
career. And he's given me so
much advice. And the advice
is both solicited and unsolicited.
And it ranges a big gamut.
There's statistics advice,
there's programming advice,
there's advice
about my mortgage,
there's advice about
how to plan my wedding.
And so it was hard to
sift through many, many words of wisdom
to answer the question. But I think--
let me take a sip of water.
I think one thing that I didn't
know at the time was going to
be so important. But
luckily, was very--
kind of like lead by example
is how to be a remote employee
that is engaged with a team.
I didn't necessarily think I
would be a remote employee,
and that changed and
most of us are now.
And I think the single greatest
advice is just pick up the phone.
Like to be a part of the
team so that you're not siloed away.
Form personal relationships.
And maybe not everyone
wants to form personal relationships,
pick up on that if
that's the case.
But to call people that you
work with and ask them a
question about work and ask them
a question about their personal life,
I think that was one
of the better lessons I've learned.
RACHEL DEMPSEY: Thanks so much.
STEPHANIE LUSSIER: Yeah.
- Thank you all for spending
your Thursday with us,
and thank you, Stephanie,
for sharing your experience
and knowledge with all of us.
This has been great. I love
the engaging conversation,
and definitely one of the
more lively chats as well. [CHUCKLES] STEPHANIE
LUSSIER: That's what
I like to hear. [LAUGHS]
- Bye all, have a great rest
of the day. Thank you so much.